what's so astonishing about the last 60
years what's the most important event
that didn't happen 60 years for months
day before yesterday corrosion was 60
years four months ago tomorrow Nagasaki
was locked
there's been no use of nuclear weapons
in England over 16 years nobody in 1945
possibly have had any confidence or any
belief that we would complete the
century no more use even though nuclear
weapons have been acquired by at least
eight nations since then in 1960 there
were known novelist CP snow was quoted
on page of the New York Times the
nuclear arm graphically disarmed
promptly intercontinental thermonuclear
war within the decade it's a
mathematical certainty that is this a
matter of good luck what's inevitable
wives policy or even unwise policy how'd
it happen